max when they showed the scenes the
horrible scenes which is I guess the
first time mass audiences saw the scenes
how did it affect you I kind of
understand how human being can do that
although I was in Switzerland we knew
more about it than the Germans maybe
because you know was a free press but
what they did to each other is
absolutely incredible
I'm Swiss and everybody says that you
know when they are bad
during the World War two said I was
Swiss but I really was Swiss
I didn't speak English so I learned it
by Marlon Brando but it really is true I
learned it phonetically in young lines
and I loved the language I cut a script
for Playhouse 90 called child of our
time and I cried when I read it only two
plays which I cried but that was one and
the name of the director was George Roy
hill he was wonderful and I did the play
with him it was very very touching play
God also nominated one even a few Emmys
after we finished I think in March he
said whenever I got a part for you I
will give it to you I went up to the
mountains and two weeks later I got a
script called judgment at number four
Playhouse 90 did Stanley Kramer see it
because not many television shows become
major movies and now comes Stanley
Kramer's great thinking and his great
talent and
I told him he saw the movie and they
asked me if I would play at the same
part again Stanley Kramer with directed
it was very flattered and Spencer Tracy
would play the leading role and Richard
Widmark and Montgomery Clift with whom I
really did the Young Lions led three
apart which didn't appear in the TV show
when a bee man wrote it already just
George Roy hill thought four players 90
with 90 minutes it was too much and Judy
Garland can you imagine you come from
Switzerland and have such a cast in
front of you was wonderful and when I
got the script I wanted to do the part
of Burt Lancaster really yeah because I
saw this play the role and yeah sitting
all all the way silent it's wonderful he
played it for him and then Stanley said
that's wonderful with this most always
like this
so I said to Spencer Spence actually you
don't have to film that several times
you could just take one tape you won the
Academy Award for Best Actor yes wasn't
Spencer Tracy the star of the film you
both nominated for Best Actress Best
Actor and I congratulated him and we
were friends we became friends and my
last speech but you see Spence had in
his contract he was older than me and he
had it in his contract that he could
come at 10 o'clock and leave at 1
o'clock and come back at 3 o'clock and
leave at 5 o'clock
otherwise his health I think was
suffering and usually people said you
know
10250 Spencer mm-hmm we're setting up
the shot you know and Spencer lupins
there are folks I think you won't do it
in this short time and he was right and
when I had my great speech he said do
you need me max for that for my close-up
and I said I don't know Spence I don't
want to keep you it's now 5 o'clock and
he said you didn't need me no I said mm
yes you you need me and he stayed that
everybody came to Spencer we did that
speech Tracy was there through the
entire speech yes there's the shots of
him yes but after 5 after 5 how long did
it take to make this movie max I think
12 weeks but that's it seems three
months seems fast
good actors